oh this place is really get up okay
chuckles el Gavilan but this is school
oh so so cool I bet looks real pretty on
me no see that's the new hipster thing
like when you guys see something
dangerous now it looks cool like no
because it's like that like there's some
oh my god that kid is so cute look at
him he looks like he's gonna whup
somebody's ass you know this place is
the heart of all I used to walk around
there in shame where my boys shirt and
they shoot that off I said [ __ ] Shh
that's my favorite accent that you do or
this one over here and Annika you think
whatever don't worry I'm gonna be the
[ __ ] Uther no game I'll ever say
[ __ ] don't worry
huh oh yeah never watch 90s horn 80s
porn
their hair is [ __ ] weird a shadow
curls I haven't like avidly watched porn
in years because it just got too
accessible I didn't like your that time
when porn became really just everywhere
yeah like you were super happy about it
but then you get done with it really
fast cuz then this is the same thing and
on top and I think the girls got uglier
really number one why the [ __ ] are every
I'm not saying every asian porn star I
know y'all got feelings and stuff but
you don't say some of y'all be not the
creme de la creme
I got into it with an asian porn star
all right so this girl right I guess she
retired
I'll bleep out the name to say I had a
lot of no poor starts name says I don't
know she's what because I've never heard
of her in my life I don't know who she
was but then I get a text message
screenshot from my friend saying yo why
is this girl calling out your
photographer buddy and it's my homie if
any dope dude like super nice guys doing
great things
and that's what the book is she posted a
picture of him saying like don't work
with this guy he's a [ __ ] scary he
won't send you photos well bah bah bah
blah he'll like ghost on you and text
Benny I gave all the focuses and then
because I know Benny speaker he's always
saying dear Mina he's like that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he sends me a
screenshot of all the messages that they
exchanged he's like yeah like she wanted
all the raw photos hundreds she wanted
them all by that night emailed her No
yeah first of all this is a trade sick
of all I'm not compressing or whatever
that many [ __ ] files wrong to send
you what trade you don't usually get RAW
files yet a few edited ones that's it
you [ __ ] all about your wife she's
like no I want them all I wanted tonight
and then she was like usually in my
photographers getting to me the same day
like what the [ __ ] are you working with
that was the fun so and then he goes
okay well if you want them I'll put them
in a hard drive can pick him up she's
like no bring him to me
it's like what the [ __ ] so then because
of that she went off on Instagram like
blah blah blah whatever does that so I
called her out and I did it very nicely
because if this is the business thing
I'm gonna be like yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
well I was really nice and like this how
it works
this is trade you don't get roll
footages and the fact that he even
offered you crawl footages is a big
thing in itself but you refuse to pick
it up don't [ __ ] at other people when
you're the lazy ass who won't pick it up
yeah and then she starts going off and
I'm like yeah I've been doing this for
11 years I know what I'm talking about
and then like I said we kept it simple
the whole time and then she goes 11
years won't your old ass [ __ ] retire
then oh you don't wanna [ __ ] go there
with me cuz I'm like you what someone
says some [ __ ] and I feel like it and
I'm bored at home not doing anything
I'll pop off so I was like first of all
don't tell me to [ __ ] my tire I'm
still in my prime you're when you
retired because you couldn't stand that
one scene when they showed a [ __ ]
bottle if it was
and I don't get a [ __ ] put and uber
code on my bio because I can't pay for
my own [ __ ] I can pay for my own [ __ ]
uber rides [ __ ] and then she really
shut up and then everyone's and then
there are my fans on there too and
everyone on there was just like you know
Gina I'm like yeah need a [ __ ] dick
even on your own picture my fans are
[ __ ] showing more love and they do
for you when did this happen
damn culture so catty do y'all a crazy
once ago go stir crazy I don't like
people who don't friends so like I don't
wanna wanna say [ __ ] about you people
only say [ __ ] about me you don't nothing
but if someone says some [ __ ] about you
and I know it wasn't sure like if
someone were to say like David's a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
he [ __ ] like he's me and he's [ __ ]
like you know like he's you know I'd be
like now shut the [ __ ] down no he's not
you know but it's the thing as I kept it
civil and I made it a point to keep it
civil in business only but the moment
you start getting personal like shut cuz
she did a scene this is why she retired
she did a scene it was like a public
humiliation scene in a grocery store
we're like a bunch of dudes Buckner and
they shove things up her vagina and [ __ ]
and like shoving bottles in there and
that's what she was like you know I
can't do this no more yeah I think if I
got a bottle shoved up my ass I think
I'd be done - yeah I'm kind of like I
don't know
may I don't know like in dreams they cut
yeah I mean the Phantom was okay but the
other ones were crazy like first of all
getting a right model up your ass and
not getting sponsored is insane I'm not
sure that's crazy than so he and then so
what ended it all was he posted the
screenshot of her saying I don't want to
go get it you bring to me myself or
bring it to me and then that's what she
showed up she deleted everything what'd
she do that was not smart
that's crazy no cuz I know yeah I like
Asia the only pretty Asian pork don't
even know there's any pretty asian porn
stars you know what's funny
so you want to hear a funny story so it
was when Paul and I were doing this uh I
thought there's something good girl yeah
I'm calming maybe I'm calling maybe I'm
out of my
we're doing this video friends in that
video Evelynn the other points are yes
so like they're like oh there's gonna be
a porn star here now mind you I hadn't
been been avidly watching porn for a
while yeah so number one like you know
what I did watch porn I didn't have like
yo this was my porn star on that day
just I never got to know their name just
look at it it's watching and that's it
and that's about it you're done you did
whatever and so they're like yo there's
gonna be a porn star
and so there's three girls in was it
just like any money obviously course why
not
so from they didn't tell me what was so
in my mind I was I kind of witness bing
bang pow that [ __ ] right there she's
definitely the porn star what got the
porn star no she's Evelyn is very cute
and on top of that she's very uh she
comes out very uh she has the very
wholesome girl next door look she's very
cool yes just normal okay little girl
they're normal like girl you see it you
say like yeah yeah and the girl with the
big fake titties all tanned up was the
normal chick that razy yeah that's my
race when I first um she used to do a
couple of my club events when I used to
go dance oh they're like oh we're having
a porn sorry I saw in the flyer I was
like who the [ __ ] Little Sisters is
yeah she's really young and yeah very
nice girl I was like oh [ __ ] do those to
her friends her and the dumbest and
yours interesting too it's like you meet
a porn star in person it kind of ruins
the mist you know I mean I personally
hadn't seen her naked at that point but
now I just don't care cuz I'm Mitchell
person you two real down yeah that was
like like I can't kind of degrade you
yeah it looks like you're too real dude
the end that was the one when I was
rolling the car mask
always know I rolled the car off my look
I was like when you wash the car but
that was not okay I'll shut this down
that was the beginning of our friendship
- yeah that was a very beautiful even
ship yes yes I wasn't the [ __ ] mini
I'll save it
what oh my god wait which part do we hey
I love you I do remember I feel like
we're playing with I'm playing the lady
you know I'm not your jokes like it's
like it's ready I'm just an tight it's
baby no to play a baby
Righetti huh birthday so I playing a
joke on that you have no sense of humor
uh-huh you're not even I get it now yes
yes you were at the Palmer at the Korean
barbecue looking like a
listen booyah
r2 r2 r2 girl you are my culture my age
even maybe I just my wretched oh I'm
kidding I'm kidding
you're the part work god how long has a
[ __ ] video been I don't know I guess
I didn't even make the video and I
remember you smell like flowers I love
you you're so pretty
did you get prettier there's anything
possible oh wow I'm thinking I was in
the beach
what pop contest are we're at right are
in the video what do you mean you make
the cut Jordan it was no way of Lexi's
viewing or [ __ ] [ __ ] laying
next to me I have a picture of us from
that beat with my god I remember now
there's Huntington Beach look on you
know what people don't know this but
it's a verse in the Bible Matthew 5:18
when they'll forget it thy friend
that's when thy friendship is said
Matthew 5:18 your buddies
all right to John 3:16 someone pulled
Steve Olsen
[Music]
[Music]